à l'aéroport de Belgrade des dizaines de
passagers en provenance de Moscou parmi
eux beaucoup se sont précipités quelques
instants après le discours de Vladimir
Poutine pour réserver un vol vers
l'étranger ils ont choisi la Serbie l'un
des derniers pays à ne pas demander de
visa aux citoyens russes je suis en
train de vous parler même si j'ai peur
de mon gouvernement parce que la police
va me voir et j'aurais sûrement des
problèmes
[Musique]
mais je veux quand même dire liberté
pour l'Ukraine
s'il vous plaît que quelqu'un arrête
Poutine
pour les prochains jours tous les vols
de Moscou vers Belgrade sont complets le
nombre de réservations a également
explosé vers la Turquie ou l'Arménie
conséquence le prix des vols est
Istanbul la triplé par rapport à la
semaine dernière
ces passagers ont pris un aller simple
pas question de retourner en Russie dans
l'immédiat
je suis vrai la situation de loin je
pense qu'au 21ème siècle participait à
la guerre est une erreur je pense que
tout le monde comprend que personne ne
soutient la guerre et que c'est très
douloureux de voir que beaucoup de gens
meurent je voudrais que cela se termine
rapidement pour l'heure il n'existe
aucune restriction pour quitter le pays
mais les Russes craignent que les
frontières ne se ferment en particulier
pour les hommes en âge de combattre
l'Estonie la Lettonie et la Lituanie qui
partage une frontière avec la Russie
ont-elles considérablement durcit leur
politique de visa touristique
ce la Finlande membre de l'Union
européenne et voisine de la Russie
continue de les